[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'almanach du vieux fermier le prédit
2017 sera un univers froid et rigoureux
froid est rigoureux aussi pour le
gouvernement avec bien des tempêtes à
l'horizon un vent plutôt frais va
souffler des états unis avant inquiétant
pour certains avec l'inauguration de la
présidence de dans notre up le 20
janvier
justin trudeau lui semble avoir adopté
une approche pragmatique face au futur
président des états unis et l'ue à
relancer l'invitation espère qu en effet
dans notre homme fera son premier voyage
à l'étranger au canada
fin février début mars est ce que ça va
arriver on verra mais on n'ose imaginer
la scène entre juste être dos et dans
notre up
le jeune politicien qui fait les portés
par l'optimisme la preuve la promesse
d'améliorer la société face un président
qui lui carbure à la colère de toute une
tranche de l'électorat
donc ce sera certainement à surveiller
pendant l'hiver on l'a vu il ya un vent
glacial qui souffle en ce moment entre
ottawa et les provinces sur le dossier
de la santé avec l'échec des
négociations avant noël et surtout avec
le pari d'ottawa de briser le front
commun des provinces que toujours tenus
dans les négociations passé une entente
avec le nouveau brunswick c'est clair
qu'une stratégie là dedans de la part
d'ottawa forcer la main des provinces
obtenir des conditions de leur part
avant de délier les cordons de la bourse
ottawa veut des réformes et semble prêt
à tout pour les obtenir
ça on peut prédire ça risque de chauffer
entre québec et ottawa là dessus tout ça
bien sûr va nous mener vers la décision
la plus probablement la plus importante
du gouvernement entre dos depuis qu'il a
été élu son budget 2010 est le budget de
l'an 2 pourquoi est ce qu'il est si
important parce que le budget de l'an 1
sauf que quand on avait coulé les
fondations de la maison de redonner à la
classe moyenne baisses d'impôts et
cetera avec le budget de l'an 2 il faut
ériger les murs de la maison
dans l'environnement économique précaire
actuelle
l' architecture de tout ça sera crucial
parce que si le signal et c'est le
moment où le gouvernement entre d'eau
doit réussir à donner les moyens
d'atteindre sa promesse au canadien cell
une réelle croissance économique au pays
les rayons de soleil et les chants des
oiseaux ne suffiront pas à eux seuls
pour résoudre l'important dilemme auquel
le gouvernement trudeau est confronté
pour réaliser deux de leurs promesses
phares il ya bien sûr tout fiasco de la
réforme du mode de scrutin qu'on le veut
l'automne dernier
pourtant avant noël justin trudeau a
réitéré sa promesse de doter le canada
d'un nouveau mode de scrutin pour les
élections de 2010 9 ce qui veut dire
qu'il doit réussir à légiférer ce
printemps difficile de voir une embellie
sur ce front
dans le climat de méfiance et de
récrimination entre l'opposition et le
gouvernement et avec l'arrivée des
bourgeons verts tendres dans les arbres
sont bien sûr les bourgeons de cannabis
qui veut occuper bien davantage la
pensée de nos politiciens
pourquoi parce que c'est ce printemps
que le gouvernement trudeau va
finalement déposer son projet de loi sur
la légalisation de la marijuana et on
sait il ya d'importants choix de santé
publique et de sécurité publique qui
s'imposent pour le gouvernement et qui
rappelez-vous duo canadien il faut
légaliser la marie pour mieux protéger
les jeunes et pour lutter contre le
crime organisé le marché noir
donc il faut réussir à réconcilier ça
dans un projet de loi mais auparavant je
vous dirais que la détermination du
gouvernement dans ce dossier leur mise à
l'épreuve
bien avant parce qu'il doit lutter
contre la perception actuelle dans bien
des sphères de la société que finalement
avec la légalisation de la marijuana
fumer c'est pas si grave que ça
parlez-en d'ailleurs à tous les parents
dans les différentes villes du pays qui
habitent à proximité des dispensaires
qui poussent comme des champignons à
toronto québec vancouver montréal
un peu précoce me direz vous mais moi
dans mon esprit la longue fin de semaine
de mai a toujours marqué le début de
l'été il fait chaud on jardine on
entrevoit les vacances les militants
conservateurs russie certains rôles
esprit ailleurs parce qu'il voyait dans
le dernier droit de la longue course à
la direction du parti
parce que c'est finalement lors du
congrès des 27 et 28 mai que sera choisi
le nouveau chef conservateur
quel chef c'est vrai qu'avec 14
candidats dans la course en ce moment on
enterre parfois notre latin même nous
les journalistes politiques
on a de la difficulté à s'y retrouver en
ce moment mais c'est quand même une
course cruciale parce que c'est la
première course de l'après harper donc
c'est une course qui va avoir une
influence très importante sur l'avenir
de ce parti là parce qu'il faut
comprendre stephen harper a toujours
réussi à maintenir l'unité au sein des
différentes factions qui anime ce parti
là haut
à l'heure actuelle la course ressemble
davantage à un fractionnement des forces
au sein du parti
oui les conservateurs vont définir
l'après harper ce qui est crucial pour
leur mouvement mes soucis avec le
résultat de cette course là qu'on aura
peut-être un début de réponse à savoir
si vraiment le mouvement sous jacent que
menez a hobo exit à l'élection de dames
en 2 dans l'autre chante hé bien si
vraiment une tendance ici au canada pour
que ce mouvement-là s'exprime
parce que si tendance il y a elle aurait
à s'exprimer dans cette course là donc
ce sera un test très important
il n'y a pas que les feuille d érable
qui seront orangé cet automne la scène
politique sera en partie occupé par le
npd
et oui on oublie parfois le npd est en
pleine course à la direction
le français qui a pas de candidat en ce
moment pour briguer les honneurs de
reconstruire ce parti-là descendre de la
défaite de 2015
parce que plus une amère défaite
électorale
ce que la dernière année a aussi montré
au sein du npd c'est la fracture qui
déchire ce parti la fracture idéologique
facture tactique fracture géographique
est donc maintenant est ce que le npd
doit prendre un virage plus à gauche
plus écologiste au risque d'un schisme
avec le fragile gouvernement
néo-démocrate d'éruption nathalie en
alberta ou doit-il parier sur une
approche plus centriste mais réussir à
éviter les écueils qui ont mené à la
défaite de 2015 le npd donc vous le
voyez en 2017 est à la croisée des
chemins et donc vous voyez relations
internationales choix budgétaires et
économiques drogue démocratie paysage
politique
2010 est finalement contribuera à
définir les forces en présence en vue
des prochaines élections
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]